welcome to this video playing fat cat
from the USA let's see I have got a
streak of 14th twins 14 straight wins
can I continue the streak that's an
interesting question okay efore if he
goes e5 he knows the latest theory he
doesn't which does not mean that it's
terribly bad what is playing with if I
the sort of the the latest development
in this line okie dokie so Bishop to age
6 mm not sure I have to do this anyway
interesting Queen I've high very quickly
played not quite sure why why this was
essential I mean why would you need the
screen a5 muth be five before might be
Black's idea
okay I'm not sure if I was certainly
debatable but I think that this should
be a quite good structure he takes is
definitely good for wide and here the
open sea file is not not really an issue
for me I mean I mean he cannot use it
very much she cannot detect me now and I
have f4 f5 and h h4 h4 have ideas mm-hmm
Queen trade who not sure about that I
rather not treat the Queen's at the
moment Queen B 6 also blocked be 64
night which is certainly something that
could help right trying to play a 5
let's see what is he doing King edge
eight million know so f phi f is nothing
that concerns in very much it seems cake
sticks I will still do that it must be
good to have this f5 move in it must
help white definitely okay well the
night's to before is still nothing
nothing special you should be three here
too okay
still no no big big threats here maybe I
should just push this yeah h4 h5 playing
direct very directly I really don't see
much counter play he can play night
before but it's not even even the threat
Knight a5 c4 takes a long time Bishop
aged voice is snow but I don't think you
can grab the bond green age 3 or
something opening the H file this is
certainly certainly too much
I don't know it looks very dangerous
hmm he grabbed it ok I was thinking this
move first not sure about it now that I
look at it this is probably good as well
good night before I yes I underestimated
this one this is the kind of stupid
stuff that hurts you have Bishop d3 it's
just it's stupid move just just just
create three entities and in huge
trouble yeah okay it's not a big deal
hopefully so what now Bishop age six
snot helping
o gauge one age five maybe Bishop age
six fearsome counter some counter attack
coming somehow on the C file things like
that Queen somewhere 67 hmm rook g3 or
is this not on
you can take the form unfortunately
maybe f4 f5 I don't know it's difficult
and the time is going down you can queen
on the C file is to check on c2 I can do
this I have c1 covered by the bishop
p.m. maybe maybe maybe can I could play
g5 maybe I is doing that now take stakes
I have time for you to this first I
guess to make sure that i'm not back
ring back ranked
okay for Rupe g3
f6 I will take I think I get this
Beckham now I can take age five right I
mean maybe has a draw you might have a
draw I will see what I can actually
actually play King here to continue it's
still a very strong attack it's a bit
little bit of a gamble due to the time
situation but it keeps the pressure on
also I have a threat of f6f sick screen
age 6 Queen h6 is in fact OS give me
shackling me this just my child check
check for Roxy three check let's get the
check here Roxy three years not clear
the twins check now I'm blundering
little chat I want a lucky lucky guy
from this completely lost position check
I have to try to trick him I saw it ah
wow this was like totally winning at the
end of the streak no and he's 66 know it
just so simple it's just so simple I was
thinking and I hope to see three would
win but he of course means the Queen
ah this game it hurts he was so totally
outplayed you on the King side huh Jim
Vizier idea this is why you don't get to
2500 winning this idiotically simple
positions not winning join this even
this is made yeah he is made in to check
and mate checkmate come on ah no no no
okay I have to start a new streak what
what can you do okay thanks for watching